bonsoir arnaud benedetti merci d'être
avec nous une procuration peut être à ce
jugement du tribunal correctionnel de
paris ce qui vous a surpris en précisant
que les peines sont inférieures aux
réquisitions
c'est un juge duke est extrêmement dur
pour l'ancien président de la république
il y a finalement de lecture que l'on
peut avoir de cette décision de justice
la première lecture celle qui consiste à
dire que la justice le bras de la
justice impartiale sabah désormais
quelle que soit la position du
justiciable quand bien même serait-il
l'ancien président de la république et
puis une deuxième lecture qui est une
lecture qui eux peut-être un café très
ce ce verdict comme un bras de fer
politique entre une partie de l'autorité
judiciaire et l'ancien président de la
république c'est en tout cas la lecture
que l'on pas manqué d'en faire très
rapidement l'ensemble des soutiens
républicains de l'ancien président de la
république
effectivement quand on connaît les
rapports qu'elle veut qu'on peut être
encore d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy et une
partie des magistrats rappellent le mur
des cons etc
comment cette justice a fait rendue
sereinement
comment ne serait ce qu'un instant
finalement rendre justice de manière
sereine dans sa bouche et c'est bien
toute la question que pose d'une
certaine façon ce verdict est d'ailleurs
nombre d'instructions qui sont menées
contre l'ancien président de la
république on sait que les relations
entre nicolas sarkozy et une partie des
magistrats était particulièrement tendue
évidemment la défense de nicolas sarkozy
ne manque pas de poser le fait qu' on
peut se poser des questions sur les
méthodes qui ont été déjà utilisée cours
d'une certaine façon piégé l'ancien
président marie public une écoute
téléphonique entre un avocat et fiable
c'est quelque chose qui pose question la
possibilité qu'il ya eu une enquête
parallèle
savoir si nicolas sarkozy lui-même
enquêté sur les les investigations que
le nez la jutice comme l'a révélé
mais dom à terre le point pose aussi
question en l'occurrence la réalité
c'est que healy a vraisemblablement nino
d'interprétation la kiffe pas fait part
à l'opinion publique une partie de
l'opinion publique qui était très
anti-sarkozystes se satisfera et se
félicitera de ce verdict et puis une
autre partie de l'opinion publique qui
elle est plutôt dit laurent qui n'a
trouvé un certain nombre de qualités à
l'ancien président de la république
c'est mourra de ce verdict en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça montre qu'il
existe un profond climat de dégradation
dans ce pays de confiance dans les
institutions qu'elles soient politiques
ou judiciaires
il ya le mot indépendance on n'a pas
prononcé mais c'est de cela dont on
vient de parler de la justice il ya
également le mot acharnement qui revient
que revenu souvent dans la bouche des
républicains aujourd'hui ya un
acharnement judiciaire contre nicolas
sarkozy selon vous qu'at il y a beaucoup
de requêtes sur l'ancien président de la
république
donc le fait qu'il y ait beaucoup de
requêtes ne manque pas de laisser libre
court à ce type d'interprétation quoi il
y aurait un acharnement contre l'ancien
président de la république
ce qui est sûr c'est que nicolas sarkozy
reste une figure politique qui à droite
est une figure tutélaire en l'occurrence
et il était inévitable que ce verdict
donne lieu à une interprétation très
politique en l'occurrence et c'est ce
qui n'a pas manqué de se passer ce qui
ne manque pas de se dérouler et qui va
encore se dérouler vrai sens dans les
jours qui viennent une balle nord le
président de la république l'ancien
président de la république a fait appel
en l'occurrence et donc la procédure va
suivre son cours
déception peut être aussi dans un camp
républicain qui voient s'éloigner
peut-être un éventuel recours pour 2022
nicolas sarkozy a toujours objecter
cette éventualité c'est à dire qu'il a
toujours dit que pour lui la vie
politique était derrière lui il n'y a
aucune raison de croire sauf que lors
d'une interview qu'il avait donnée
récemment chez l'une de vos consoeurs
ruth elkrief sur une chaîne concurrente
il avait quand même laissé entendre que
si des circonstances exceptionnelles
mais ce produit peut-être qu'ils
seraient là pour rendre service à son
pays et au delà de cet effet rhétorique
on a un président de la république alors
siècle vers la libye qui manifestement
en tout cas depuis un certain nombre de
temps au regard de ses déclarations a
toujours en tout cas expliqué qu' il
était pour lui hors de question de
revenir dans le flou politique même si
on sait très bien que la vie politique
est faite parfois de surprises et de
robots avec ce jugement c'est
définitivement une affaire entendue
nicolas sarkozy quand bien même il le
souhaiterait ne reviendra pas il est
clair que c'est un jugement qui
handicape fortement une éventualité de
ce type parce que c'est un jugement très
sévère et que vous savez aussi que il y
aura bientôt un autre rendez vous
judiciaire pour nicolas sarkozy dans la
sphère dit 2 bygmalion donc il ya là
disons un calendrier judiciaire qui de
toute façon j'aime profondément
handicapée un éventuel retour de nicolas
sarkozy dans l'arène politique je
rappelle quand même que il avait fait un
retour dans l'arène politique en 2016
après que ça lors de sa défaite de 2012
il est là aussi dit son intention de ne
jamais revenir et que ce retour n'a pas
été probant là sur le plan politique
puisque lors de la primaire qui avaient
été celles des républicains
nicolas sarkozy avait été battu par
françois fillon et par alain juppé merci
beaucoup arnaud benedetti rédacteur en
chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire merci d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france